immediately to the north of me the state
of oklahoma is dealing with brutal
wind and snow but unlike texas they
actually
have power my colleague medea virial is
in oklahoma city to explain medea
hey thanks omar you know here's the deal
right now it's about eight degrees here
in oklahoma city it has been snowing for
about 12 hours straight it is snowing
right now and so
the question remains why is it possible
or how is it possible that oklahoma
is faring better than texas here's what
it boils down to oklahoma actually
shares a power grid with its neighbors
here's what it breaks down to the state
gets its energy from the southwest power
pool
along with 13 other states so when the
temperature dipped down
in oklahoma and demand went up the pool
had enough energy available and reserved
to respond to this emergency
like omar said texas has its own power
grid that is run by the company ercot it
doesn't have the luxury of relying on
other states for help
and even within texas there are
communities not
impacted as severely by power outages
places like el paso
where just about a hundred people are
without power and the reason
is that region is on a completely
different power grid it's owned
separate from the company that supplies
about 90 percent of the state with its
power i mean here's what it boils down
to i'm
out of town right now my neighbor goes
and checks on my house and so in moments
of crisis it's extremely important to
have that
neighbor connection right right now in
oklahoma we understand there are no
rolling power outages but that could
change depending on the weather
throughout the day
but i've talked to a lot of people that
say right now they are conserving as
much energy as they can
to prevent that at their homes and their
businesses as well
a lot of big questions about the power
supply there in texas maria thank you
very much we appreciate